[Musik]
das podcast ist platin blm juni schon
vor ausführlich sagen im voraus
bildungsgang das ist nicht nur das sind
nicht alles was ich unter antike
philosophie verstehen würde
denn ein ticket lose wie drei eigentlich
3 2 ghz mindestens drei philosophie ist
mindestens dreimal entstanden
anscheinend völlig unabhängig
voneinander
nämlich in indien eine zuerst indien
china und unter den griechen in
griechenland kann man nichts sagen weil
die vorsänger vorwiegend in griechenland
waren
dazu könnte man auch betrachten ob man
philosophie hat man anerkennen will
dass philosophie in brasilien existiert
hat und wahrscheinlich noch plausibler
in ägypten und wie ich würde fast sagen
dass wir eher damit zu tun haben dass
wir indische philosophie haben die die
webers und buddhismus und nachfolgende
traditionen china konfuzianismus
tourismus und dann mittelmeerraum
grob gesagt und das wäre ägypten und die
griechen und dann später die du immer
allerdings haben wir nichts jetzt
genügend zeit das alles abzudecken und
ich werde nicht der wird nur auf
griechische also für das vieh in der
griechischen sprache konzentrieren und
eigentlich nur auf platon einst ort ließ
also das ist eine sehr klassische
methode antike floss wie abzudecken
aber ich wollte ich wollte schon im
voraus sagen ein ticket lösen ist so
groß griechische antike flusses so groß
wir machen diesen teilen davon den
berühmtesten teil weil wir nur zehn
sitzungen hafen
und ich wollte dass sie alle etwas über
platten und hat dies erfahren damit sie
sich vorbereiten können für spätere
kurse so ein team das wie alle denken
werde ich zur zwei andere themen
berühren mindestens erstens wird es eine
sitzung zur weiblichen den weiblichen
denkerinnen der antike geben und frauen
also was platte machen dass dort nichts
über frauen sagen weil ich dafür wenn
das man in jeder periode der flüsse wie
man erkennt dass es nicht nur männliche
philosophen gegeben hat sondern auch
weibliche philosophinnen erstens dass
und zweitens in der letzten sitzung
werde ich sehr kurz was über diese
spätere zeit in der klasse wie sie sagen
also auch eine mystische plastische oder
spätantike zeit
ok also wenn wir uns jetzt nur auf die
griechische philosophie konzentrieren
was bietet die antike unter
philosophischen texten
das fängt mit den vorzug karte können
die insekten oder sechsten jahrhundert
vor christus
und wie gesagt nicht in griechenland
selbst sondern auf der küste der
jetzigen türkei vor allem denkt man an
die stadt
militos normalerweise der dirigent der
denker der als der erste fußballer zeit
anerkennt wird ist alles teil ist von
als militär 17 17 jahrhundert vor
christus ist vielleicht ein beispiel
dafür dass ägyptische wissenschaft und
für sowie doch hier relevant ist weil er
angeblich in ägypten war und deutsch
mathematik gelernt hat nach
alles hat man bekannte namen wie zum
beispiel heraklit immer noch und in der
türkei noch nicht ungeplant paar männer
dies und empedokles auch nicht in
griechenland aber dann denke wie alexa
dass der doch in athen war und dann
haben wir natürlich stalker ts denn sie
nur ein also eine zahl merken wollen wir
die ganze antike philosophie würde ich
empfehlen dieses jahres zu merken 399
gut daher 99 dass der das jahr sorgte
dieses gestorben ist bzw umgebracht
worden ist von den netten kommilitonen
und dass es erstens gut zu merken war
erstens sind sie voll sind die vor so
kritiker vorsorge ist und deswegen hat
man so seine grenze ok for sogar dass
wir uns dann irgendwie wird er vor dem
vierten jahrhundert vor christus also
fünfter sechster jahrhundert vor
christus
und natürlich kommen platon und
aristoteles unmittelbar danach deswegen
kann man bemerken okay dann sind leiter
des vierten jahrhundert vor christus
und dann kommen die restliche
philosophen der antike also sein
sozusagen ein wenn nicht einen
mittelpunkt mindestens ein guter punkt
den man merken kann und ich finde auch
diese diese zahl ist auch leicht zu
merken
das ist auch gut was geschieht nach
platin resort ließ wie gesagt das werde
ich in der letzten sitzung etwas länger
diskutieren aber kurzum entstehen
mehrere schulen der philosophie weil da
hätte man auch weitere schulen
aufscheinen können zum beispiel die
zenica aber die hauptschulen sind drei
historiker die apple korea und die
skeptiker
da ist es auffällig und vielleicht für
uns überraschend dass wir in der
hellenistischen zeit unter helle
mystische zeit in der philosophie das
bringt da versteht man normalerweise so
spät vierte jahrhundert vor christus bis
vielleicht erste jahrhundert vor oder
nach christus je nachdem wen man fragt
aber mehr oder weniger die zeit die man
auch in der normalen geschichte also
nicht geschichte sowieso eine geschichte
geschichte als realistisch beschreibt
also die zeit der bahn erreichen die
nach alexander der große entstanden sind
und römische republik
zeit also dass das das bringt das zuerst
jahrhundert vor christus und danach ein
stets komisches imperium und dann haben
wir mehrere bänke spätantike an ist für
uns was sie dann sagen wollte dass das
für uns auffällig ist dass platin ismus
und des sozialismus in dieser zeit
nichts so prägend sind wir können fast
nichts sagen dass wir eine platonische
schule in dieser zeit haben oder eine
restschule warum einzelne denker die von
den von plattformen von den werken
platons model dieses beeinflusst wurden
aber keine platonische schule bzw
haben wir schon die sogenannte akademie
die schule des partners aber die
akademie ist skeptisch geworden und
haben vor allem werke wie zum beispiel
diese
berg weiß ich was ich besprechen werde
heute männern aufgenommen und gesagt was
platon immer uns beim sokratis machen
wollten ist leute sagen dass sie keine
ahnung haben wenn es um tiefgehende
fragen wie zum beispiel was die tugend
diese fragen können sie nicht
beantworten und alle fragen alle
beantwortet die bisher sind diese fragen
gegeben würden sind entweder falsch oder
haben wenn es um probleme die nicht noch
nicht gelöst worden sind und deswegen
sind die skeptiker behaupten
entweder behaupten sie dass wir keine
wissen besitzen oder sie behaupten dass
wir kein bisschen verlag erwerben können
sogar das sind die skeptiker die
historiker und apple korea haben ihre
eigene gründe
mehrere wenigen derzeit das alles bot
ließ nämlich sie nun von kitty um der
gründer der stock der schule und
natürlich epikur der gründe der smp
organismus und diese drei traditionen
sind sehr stark in der zeit des so bis
früh in das römische imperium kann man
sagen das sieht man sogar ist zum
beispiel dass marc aurel ein römischer
kaiser selbst oracle hat und hat story
schöpften verfasst war wahrscheinlich
der mächtigste philosoph aller zeiten
marko rehmer
bis ich dann in der spätantike und hier
haben wir eine zeit die von historikern
und für das wir solchen oft etwas
vernachlässigt wird das ist die zeit
nach den höhepunkt des römischen
imperiums das ist das in zeiten wo man
oft mehr als ein kaiser pro jahr hat zb
ist super verwirrend oder man hat
entweder eine reihe von kaiser in die
alle sterben oder wie sage dies
umgebracht werden oder wir haben mehrere
kreise in mehreren bereichen des
imperiums super kompliziert wenn
philosophie es auch etwas kompliziert
war die hauptströmung in dieser zeit ist
neu platin ismus das würde von platin im
dritten jahrhundert nach christus
begründet er selbst hat sich nicht als
neue platte mittel gesehen sondern
einfach als platonische also erst als
sich als treuer anhänger des platzes
muss er hat aber themen aus den anderen
philosophischen richtungen mit platin
ismus kombiniert zum beispiel hat er
viele ideen haus übernommen und auch als
tourismus es muss uns gassis muss man
ihn nicht so beeinflusst
wenn dann dann nur negativ zum beispiel
wollte er mehrere skeptische argumente
irgendwie überwinden aber es ist gewiss
kein skeptiker oder apple
apples mac os muss als philosophie geht
wirklich ist praktisch nicht mehr in
mode
nach lukas ersten also im ersten oder
zweiten jahrhundert vor christus an
nachwuchs gibt es sehr wenige von
evergreens missouri und das kommt erst
in der früh moderne zurück nachdem diese
strömung susan wieder entdeckt würde
auch in der spätantike was man leicht
vergisst ist das christentum dann das
imperium übernimmt man das vergisst man
nicht aber was man vergessen ist dass
wir viele philosophen schon in der
spätantike haben die christen sind und
keine heidnische denke wie platin und
die anderen platonischer zum beispiel
augustinus oder poitiers die manchmal
oder sogar vorwiegend als
mittelalterliche denker betrachtet
werden wahrscheinlich einfach weil sie
auf latein geschrieben haben
aber sie selbst sein sich definitiv als
bürger des römischen reiches und sie
waren wirklich immer noch in einer
kürzeren situation die nicht
mittelalterlich war noch nicht mit
örtlich war sondern spätantike okay das
ist ein ticket lotterie sozusagen in
einem satz
was danach kommt ist natürlich eine sehr
deutliche philosophie und zwar in
mindestens drei traditionen
wir haben naheliegenden latein
mittelalter wo sie selbst sehr
beeinflusst von augustinus und boris
sind also lateinische werke und all
diese griechische werke kaum lesen
können bei matthias ott ließ nur sehr
teilweise gleich bei platon noch weniger
sie haben nur eine unvollständige
übersetzung eines dialogs platons wenn
mit dem team
folglich haben sie nur die logik und die
deutliche werke von klarträumen örtlich
sind verschraubt sind für sie nicht
greifbar im gegensatz dazu ist die
situation in business und in der
islamischen welt im brisanz haben sie
alles was wir haben
per definitionem weil wir diese werke
nur haben weil wir die handschriften aus
bis ans haben also alles was bis dahin
wie sonst gefällt hat ist jetzt verloren
und dann in der islamischen welt haben
sie arabische übersetzungen von den
philosophen der antike vor allem haben
sie fast alles von alles dort ließ was
wir haben haben sie auf arabisch weniger
von platon aber mindestens paraphrasiert
haben sie mehrere dialoge platons und
dann haben sie andere denker vor allem
aus der spätantike wie zum beispiel
kritik
man könnte ich sogar weiter gehen und
sagen das griechische philosophie alle
kulturelle bereiche erreicht die
sozusagen geografisch zugänglich sind
also nicht china und indien anscheinend
aber zum beispiel armenien es gibt
armenische übersetzungen georgische
übersetzungen und sogar äthiopische
übersetzungen von griechen werken
es gibt werke die in einem in einer
sparte namens kies verfasst wurden die
von christen in äthiopien dann verfasst
wurden als übersetzungen haus
griechischen quellen nicht glatt ein
anderes ort wie es aber andere werke die
philosophische weisheit zusammen
zusammen war zusammenbringt
ich denke das ist wirklich großartige
vorstellung wie antike philosophie dann
weiter lebt hat es sehr ist in der regel
sehr falsch weil wir denken immer es
gibt antike philosophie
das ist griechischen vielleicht an
dateien und dann gibt es mittel alte und
das lateinische oder päischen
christliche philosophie aber diese in
der keine situation ist nur ein kleiner
teil von einer sehr breiten einem
breiten phänomen nämlich die
überlieferung der griechischen
philosophie und theologie wie gesagt in
allen richtungen bis ins zentral asien
durch die islamische welt um den
schwarzen meer georgien armenien bis ans
sogar afrika in äthiopien und dann
europa europa gewinnen also dieses
islamische welt ist auch teilweise
europa weil mittelalter spanien und
portugal ist und der islamischen
herrschaft sind also der einfluss von
antiken torso wie im mittelalter ist
viel viel breiter als wir normalerweise
anerkennen
das war großes ein großes bild und jetzt
diskutieren wir was wie viel
detaillierter nämlich ein werk von
platon zuerst ein bisschen zu platons
selbst hat ist das wissen viele von
ihnen wahrscheinlich schon aber erstens
ist er der größte philosoph aller zeiten
oder mit aristoteles der größte
philosophie ist ohne zweifel der
einflussreiche und einfluss
einflussreichsten denker derzeit
mindestens im europäischen rahmen
aber durch paris hat plattform natürlich
auch viel einfluss und wir können auch
so einer gewissen grade sagen dass
platon für sie erfunden hat
er ist der erste der das wort
philosophie verwendet für das was wir in
zb energie gmbh philosophie gesprächen
in china oder indien gibt gibt es dieses
wort nichts also wenn ich sage dass zb
konfuzianismus oder oder hindu hindu
schulen in der flüsse wie philosophie
cent das mach ich weiß sie mich und
anderen so stark an themen erinnern die
bei platon zu finden sind aber zusagen
der prägend und sogar definieren für
philosophie normalerweise ist platon in
dem alle themen die er in seinen
dialogen aufgreift für uns als
philosophie zum beispiel also wie soll
mein leben metaphysik das existiert und
kosmologie was es wissen und wie können
wir wissen erwerben das kommt alles
zusammen bei platon in seinen dialogen
und man kann sogar sagen dass er nicht
nur alle hauptfragen der verluste wie
mehr oder weniger auf einmal entdeckt
sondern viele von den neuen den
wichtigsten naheliegenden antworten auf
diese fragen dann bietet oft mehrere
fragen beantworte für jede frage weil er
eben dialoge schreibt wo verschiedene
figuren dann verschiedene ansichten zu
den diesen zu diese philosophische
fragen vertreten
also man könnte sagen dass selbst wenn
es keine für sich je nach plattform
gegeben hätte hätten wir trotzdem
philosophie und deswegen wird das mag
mal gesagt das ist das klischee dass ich
das jetzt sage aber ich werde sowieso
zitieren
es wird oft gesagt dass die ganze
geschichte der flüsse wie fußnoten zu
platon
jetzt habe ich jetzt gesagt tut mir
passt wie die sagt platten hat keine
traktate geschrieben sondern dialoge
waren auch briefe von ihm die aber
umstritten sind also in entsetzlich ob
sie authentisch sind also für uns sind
die wichtige werke platons alle dialoge
es gibt auch dialoge von ihm die nicht
echt sind
es gibt umstrittene dann gibt es die
lobby die alle von allen als falsch
anerkannt so war es zugeschrieben
anerkannt werden
aber wir haben viele dialoge von ihm die
wirklich echt sind auffällig hier ist
die tatsache dass soweit wir wissen
haben wir nicht nur viele dialoge
platons sondern alle dialoge die er
geschrieben hat
wir haben keinen grund zu vermuten dass
es weitere theologe gegeben hat die
nicht erhalten sind und damit sie ein
alter muss sie sehen wie selten
das ist von dieser ganzen zeit und das
ist natürlich mehr als 1000 jahre die
ich skizziert habe gibt es nur einen
einzigen anderen denke wofür wir alle
für solche texte erhalten haben
also ich denke die mehr als einen ein
berg geschrieben haben also die also hat
wollen die mehrere werke geschrieben
haben es gibt nur einen bewegen wir alle
werke erhalten haben nämlich
[Musik]
ich rede hier über griechische literatur
nicht lateinische nicht als ort ist bei
weitem nicht
wir haben weniger als die hälfte kann
alles ort ließ gott sei dank
nein
trittin war es seine schule rios seine
werke agiert hat ihn eine in einer
sammlung die noch erhalten ist
das ist ein zeichen und es symptomatisch
dafür also von einer tatsache die ich
schon erwähnt habe nämlich die werke die
wir lesen können sind die werke die die
byzantiner kopiert haben wir haben
handschrift mit der hand kopiert und das
heißt die haben bestimmt was wir lesen
können und was nicht
und weil platin ismus interessant so
wichtiger und neue platz muss haben sie
die mögen geben platon gesamt als
gesamtwerk zu erhalten und auch putin
während viele andere denken nur
bruchstücke und harmonieren kann zum
beispiel für historiker sind völlig
verloren ein sehr gutes beispiel spielt
spiel werde christoph einen flur
historiker der wahrscheinlich unter den
wichtigsten und als sicherlich schlossen
philosophen in der antike ist kein
einziges werk von ihm erhalten so wir
kennen ihn nur durch reportage in
schweden denken was er gesagt hat aber
plattform im team haben wir alles okay
also was haben wir dann für platon
normalerweise spricht man hier von drei
phasen seine werke früher dialoge
mittlere dialoge und später dialoge
natürlich ist es viel komplizierter als
das und es umstritten oft welche dialoge
zu welcher phase gehören aber grobe kann
man sagen
dass die frühe dialoge sehr von sokratis
sein lehrer geprägt sind
da kommt immer socke thies aus
hauptfigur vor trifft an den menschen
stellt eine frage oder mehrere fragen
aber klassisch stellte eine frage wie
zum beispiel was ist frömmigkeit oder
was es tapfer zu sein
normalerweise ist dieser handel ist die
andere person jemand die eigentlich eine
gute antwort haben sollte zum beispiel
fragt er in la ist fragt er einen
general was tapferkeit ist und der
general kann die antwort kann die frage
nicht beantworten
und in diesen sogenannten frühen oder
sokratischen dialogen wird die andere
person also der mit starkem anhalt gibt
es mehr als eine an dem match becker
wird immer wieder legt und am ende
stehen sie beide da mit leeren händen zu
sein und wissen immer noch nicht wie man
die frage beantworten sollte deswegen
haben die skeptiker gedacht okay ich
sokratische lehre ist dass wir kein
wissen besetzen ok dann kommt die und
übrigens viele viele leute denken dass
in dieser frühen phase platten mehr oder
minder nur sokratis wie er war wieder
gibt also so seine treue reportage die
sorge diese argumentiert hat ich
persönlich halte das für blödsinn
das einzige was wir haben womit wir so
demokratische lehre bestimmen können
außer platon werke von zwei andere art
von zeno von der historiker und auch
anhänger von taxis und herr ist offen es
als offenes in seinem theaterstück macht
sich lustig über socket ist eine von für
ärzte sehr und und beschreibt auch wie
er war zeigt auch wie er in dialog mit
handel
immer wieder lösungen geführt hat also
das sorge dass andere leute dann befragt
hat und widerlegt hat das ist klar aber
die einzelheiten jedes dialogs sind
meiner meinung nach auf platons
zurückzuführen und nicht auf echte
gespräche die platon persönlich erlebt
hat das ist ihm die frühere phase
mittlere phase sind die bekannteste
werke platons vor allem die polit er
wahrscheinlich also vielleicht das
wichtigste meisterwerk in der geschichte
der philosophie
vielleicht ist das ist ein in zehn
büchern und sehr kompliziertes werk zur
politischen fluss wie ethische flüsse
wie mathe physik da hat man die ideen
theorie die man sehr stark mit plattform
verbindet dieses werk werden bei später
in einer weiteren vorlesung besprechen
und wenn man von mittleren dialogen
plattform steht was man damit die
normalerweise in mind ist werke die uns
an die politiker erinnern also die
thematisch oder oder dramatisch
irgendwie mit dem mit der politik
einzuordnen sind
dann gibt es die sogenannte spätere
werke platin platten wo es oft mehr um
technische fette physische oder sogar
logisch fragen geht
und das letzte was er das wissen hier
das letzte was er geschrieben hat ist
ein riesenberg namens gesetze nicht
normal afrikas wo er wo er vorschlägt
wie man ähnlich wie in der politik
schlägt vor wie eine perfekte
staatsregierung ist typisch für die
spätere dialog ist das so thies als
hauptspeicher ausfällt manchmal so
katies anwesend er ist aber
typischerweise nicht der hauptspeicher
stattdessen haben wir zum beispiel paar
männer dies in einem dialog namens power
manager als halbstarker uns doch diese
ist da als junger mann aber sorgt dies
wird widerlegt und dann macht parlament
ist weiter mit seiner philosophie also
die die ganze breite der platonischen
werken werde ich natürlich in ein paar
vorlesungen nicht beschreiben können
ich werde mit den männern heute anfangen
und dann werden wir einzelne themen haus
an der bekannten theologen in den
kommenden wochen beschreiben
falls sie mehr so platon oder diese
ganze geschichte erfahren wollen als ich
jetzt sagen kann
das habe ich ja auf der hand dass ab dem
plan für die für die ganze für das ganze
geschehen
aber falls sie interesse haben können
sie mit podcast hören dann danach wie
manche studierende weil sie das von mir
sieben mal gehört haben
er ist irrt sich immer wieder zu
erwähnen
das ist auf englisch ist und deckt die
ganze geschichte der philosophie ab da
erscheint eine folge pro woche und am
sonntag erreiche ich die drei
hundertstel folge
und das ende der ein der mit leidlich
inklusive also bisher habe ich gar
gänzlich antike für das vieh abgedeckt
sowie an der islamischen welt
latein christentum mitläufer sowie und
fange jetzt mit santino chef lose wie
dann gibt es eine weitere reihe über
indische philosophie dass es etwas wie
70 folgen
und das übrigens dass das ist das gehört
nicht zu die 300 weise eigene gibt es
270 schon und gerade jetzt habe ich
einen neuen reihe über afrikanische
klose wie angefangen jetzt hat jemand
drängende fragen zu dem was ich schon
gesagt habe ich dann weitergehe
er hat nichts geschrieben richtung also
wissen sogar dass er nichts geschrieben
hat er hat nun gespräche geführt
also wir können auch sagen dass alle
also trivial könnte man sagen dass alle
seine werke auch erhalten sind
weil es keine gegeben hat ich weiß nicht
was ein mathematiker dazu sagen würde
würde sie können einfach hästräger
verlas wie google das ist das erste was
sie sehen werden
oder ich glaube die die webseite ist auf
dem seminarplan oder auf dem kommunismus
polizei gut so - das ist ein weg ist
also normalerweise würde man denken mit
und ist typisch für flöhe sokratische
dialoge aber wie gesagt es ist manchmal
schwierig die einzelne dialoge wirklich
in diesen drei phasen einzuordnen und
das ist ein gutes beispiel männern wird
manchmal als übergangs dialog zwischen
früher und mittelbetrieben weil er so
dramatisch gesehen schaut es sehr
ähnlich wie die andere frühe dialoge aus
sollte dies trifft jemanden sagt kannst
du mir diese frage beantworten er
versucht die frage zu beantworten wird
widerlegt
und die gehen weiter und weiter und
kommen und kommen zu kein ergebnis
also grob gesehen er ist mein englisch
wie andere frühe werke andererseits
haben wir in männern mehr als nur eine
widerlegung einer ethisch eines versuchs
eine ein ethisches einem ethischen
begriff zu definieren das haben wir
schon aber wir haben vorwiegend nicht
nur ein gespräch über die tugend sondern
ein gespräch über apples theologie und
auch
sogar über die die voraussetzungen die
jede gute definition haben sollte
übrigens amt haben alle schon das hemd
für jungen männern jetzt die habe es
gibt hier ein paar
die herren als werden sie jetzt glauben
also erstens ist das typisch für die
mittlere dialoge
das klang etwas positiver seine eigene
app ist logische theorien entwickelt und
das tut er männern vor allem werden wir
heute ist noch sehen dass er eine
adwords ansteigenden schräge theorie
über das erwerben des wissens hier
vorschlägt nämlich dass wir nie was
lernen sondern immer nur daran hat daran
erinnert werden
wenn wir etwas wissen also erstens dass
zweitens gibt es in diese in diesem
dialog eine auseinandersetzung etwas
indirekt mit den ich so festen und das
ist vielleicht ein merkmal was durch die
ganze karriere platons dann geht aber
mit
es gibt einen anderen dialog mitnehmen
man am leichtesten den männern
vergleichen könnte und das ist der gast
wo socke dies mit dem berühmtesten
unwetter leerer rhetorik lehrer tobias
spricht ihn widerlegt und dann auch
andere anhänger von georgios widerlegt
also man könnte sagen dass in männern
und georgios zusammen
klattens zeigt wie sotheby's auf
georgios und seine anhänger reagiert hat
nämlich sehr kritisch oder anders anders
gesehen können wir sagen dass hier
platten selbst auf georges reagiert
männern ist und es wird deutlich aus dem
dialog wenn sie das lesen männern ist
ein schüler von von golden girls lebt
nicht in athen war aber so besuch in
athen und männern hat von ihm damals
reden gehört und war sehr beeindruckt
und er ist also anhänger von goyas vera
die us-airlines so fest wer waren diese
listen komplizierte frage also könnte
leicht jetzt gibt für die restliche zeit
nur erklären wer die sophisten waren
aber kurz kommen weil es die lehrer die
vor allem rhetorik in antiken
griechenlands gelehrt haben vor allem in
demokratischen städten wie athen die
touristen haben mit demokratie zu tun
weil die art und weise wie man
politisches einfluss hin zum beispiel
athen gehabt hat im gegensatz zum
beispiel fußball reden zu halten die
überzeugen wollen
es gab eine volksversammlung aus
natürlich nicht aus dem ganzen mit
nichts von dem ganzen volk sondern von
den wohlhabenden männern die kamen
zusammen und haben beschlüsse gemacht
und würden dann von guten reden
beeinflusst auch wenn man ein prozess
geführt hat waren die prozesse durch
reden verstarb an veranstaltet also die
der es gab eine rede für die
verteidigung und eine rede gegen den
verteidigten und ein gutes beispiel
davon ist die apologie die der von
platon haben wo er den prozess der socke
tietz bescheid
typischerweise für ihn sagt zug liess am
anfang der polit der apologie dass er
keine weitere kunst hat und keine gute
rede halten kann
also er wird nur sein bestes tun und
dann natürlich halte eine brilliante
rede moment bringen also die man können
kann deswegen sagen dass die sophisten
professionelle lehrer waren die
vorhandenen junge männer ausgebildet
haben und beigebracht haben besser reden
zu können damit sie dann mehr einfluss
in der stadt haben konnten also es war
wirklich der toreck im dienst
politischen einfluss und um diese lehre
dann vielleicht einer theoretischen
einen theoretischen lust zu geben haben
die sophisten verschiedene vielleicht
können wir sogar sagen er ist im
logische theorien entwickelt zum
beispiel dass man für oder gegen jede
these überzeugend argumentieren kann und
vielleicht sogar dass die kunst der
natürlich genau dafür gedacht ist also
für wurde als pro oder contra ist
orientieren meine meine tochter hat
übrigens gerade gestern in der schule
das machen müssen haben sie vielleicht
viele von ihnen im gymnasium machen
müssen oder das debattieren lernt man
und mit regen dafür so typisch für dafür
ist immer noch man kriegt eine these und
eines eine mannschaft muss dafür
argumentieren eine mannschaft dagegen es
geht nicht darum recht zu haben
es geht darum die täter sind gut zu
verteidigen
die mann zugeordnet wickelt hat übrigens
meine tochter dürft ihr das auf englisch
macht also die haben das innerhalb
englischunterricht gemacht also ich hab
gesagt du gehst in einem messer kampf
und bringt es ein maschinengewehr
und sie hat sich total sorgen gemacht
dass die anti der schule dann
schwierigkeiten haben weil sie kommt mit
ihrer fließenden englisch aber es war
okay glaube ich kurze geschichte zu ihr
als sie also frisch in deutschland
wollen hat sie dann zum ersten mal
englisch unter druck gehabt und ich habe
gefragt wie der englischlehrer sei nach
einer woche oder so und jetzt sagt gut
gut ganz gut bisher hat er keine fehler
gemacht
ok auf jeden fall also dass während man
immer noch die retterrolle kunst also
die man habe beiden seiten argumentiert
und von ist gold ja sehr eng damit
verbunden das ist genau die these die er
im dialog alias dann vorstellt eine
interessante frage die ich hier nicht
gar nichts fehl am platz ist wie sie
sehen werden ist ob die sophisten auch
behauptet haben dass sie die tuben auch
lernen konnten
wir haben aus anderen quellen
die reportage des goldes selber das
abgelehnt hat also praktisch immer
gesagt ich kann euch zeigen wie ihr
überzeugender argumentiert
ich kann euch aber nicht besser machen
als menschen das liegt bei euch zu sein
das ist nicht meine aufgabe ich bin nur
rhetorik lehrer im georgi es aber also
in dem dialog namens korrigiert
vielleicht man hat den eindruck dass er
das dass er vielleicht an dass er
vielleicht sich schämt wenn er nichts
behauptet dass er seine schüler besser
machen kann sagte thiess wird ihn
sozusagen zuzugeben dass er auch die
jugend lernen kann
aber das scheint historisch falsch zu
sein erwähnten und ist deswegen nicht
zufällig dass man an dieser schule von
georgios genau mit dieser frage
diesen dialog anfängt kann man die
tugend lernen oder nicht wenn man sie
nicht lernen kann wie er wird man die
tugend einfach durch die natur oder
anderswie das ist der erste satz den
dialog ist kein keine beschreibung der
zähne oder sowas das übrigens immer der
fall bei platon im plattform gibt es nie
diese weiß nicht wie sie auf deutsch
heißen aber diese
weise wie im theaterstück wie wie die
zähne aus schaut oder wer anwesend ist
oder so es geht einfach los mit sprache
immer mit einem satz in diesem fall ist
der erste satz die frage von männern
kann man die toten lernen oder nicht
manchmal werden die zu festen sogar als
relativ ist angeordnet weil das könnte
man schon aus dem was sie gerade über
gorgast gesagt habe könnte man daraus
gewinnen wenn er sagt ich kann für alles
überzeugend argumentieren könnte man es
klingt auch ein bisschen skeptisch also
wenn man genauso gut oder so überzeugen
für eine these argumentieren kann wie
für die konter these in jedem fall
könnte man leicht die idee haben
ok dann gibt es keine endgültige
begründung für eine these gegen die
konzert asse es gibt nur die nun her und
dieses label service muss ja es scheint
auch bei einem anderen sehr bekannten
oder sehr berühmten so festnahme des
pythagoras auszutauschen
er hat eine these vertreten die man oft
durch seine lateinische übersetzung dann
bezeichnet die idee sogenannten homo
mensur satz so homo mensch ist mensch
ist das maß auf griechisch oder von der
griechischen übersetzt heißt es der
markt der mensch ist das maß aller dinge
der seinen dass sie sind der nicht sein
dass sie nicht sind natürlich nicht ganz
klar wie man das auslegen soll
vielleicht heißt hier seien also sein
dass sie sind das könnte heißen sowie an
die tatsachen
also wie gesagt die wie die sachen sind
kann nur der mensch bezahlen also der
wir bewerten die sachen wie sie sind und
wie sie nicht sind und das kann man so
richtig auslesen wenn man wenn man davon
ausgeht dass er hier nicht die
menschheit insgesamt dann meint sondern
jeden einzelnen mensch also ich und
jeder von ihnen gewollt für sich was die
wahrheit ist für uns also ich zum
beispiel ich empfinde dass es hier sehr
warm ist weil ich vielleicht gebe habe
sie vielleicht nicht empfinden sie auch
das war mist
das entwendete sie alle dass es warm ist
das ist dann kein gutes beispiel
ok manche von ihnen empfinden
wahrscheinlich dass die vorlesung bisher
recht langweilig war habe die große
mehrheit nicht öffentlich und vortages
würde ich hier vielleicht sagen die die
schlechtere studierende die das bisher
langweilige von machen die für sie ist
die police und wirklich langweilig und
es ist naheliegend natürlich wenn sie
die vorlesung langweilig finden dann ist
sie für sie langweilig handel andere
denken angesichts des brillanten stoffes
und abenteuerliches deutsch weil weil
die vorlesung bisher ist sehr
unterhaltsam und interessant ist für sie
interessant und man man könnte sagen die
von jetzt an sich ist weder langweilig
noch interessant sondern sondern beides
oder vielleicht sogar nicht beides
sondern ist die frage wie sie ist nur
relevante man wenn man beträgt für wen
also für für ist die lage für base sie
interessant genau diese auslegung der
sumo männer satzes findet man in einem
weiteren dialog von platon name des
täters und an diesem anhand dieses
beispiels sehen wir dass platon wirklich
wirklich sorgen macht wenn er hört wie
die sophisten dann reden und
argumentieren und wie und vor allem wie
sie junge männer in athen dann erziehen
dass sie eine einstellung verbreiten
dass man die war keine absolute wahrheit
erreichen kann sondern nur überzeugung
meinung vielleicht gibt es sogar eine
histologische theorie dahinter dass es
keine objektive tatsachen gibt sondern
nur die feststellung die jeder für sich
macht wenn das essen eines sind nicht so
klar dass das wirklich sagen wollte aber
so kann man ihn aus legen sie sehen weil
es liegt vielleicht sogar nicht einmal
sagen aber das soll gezeigt
dieses thema ist natürlich für uns in
dieser zeit super relevant also die
frage gibt gibt es fakten gibt es
tatsachen im märz susan oder gibt es nur
verschiedene meinungen und es kommt
drauf an auf welchem block west oder aus
welcher politischen richtung ankommt
oder gibt es wirklich eine objektive
wahrheit die man entweder treffen kann
oder nichts mit den aussagen und platon
ist der von aller zeiten der große held
der objektiven wahrheit es genau was er
haben wollte
wir kommen später in späteren
vorlesungen zu seiner ideen lehre und
die ideen werde etwas wie der satz von
vortages ist schwer zu verstehen und aus
lägen aber unter anderem war die idee
wäre sicherlich ein versucht zu zeigen
was die voraussetzungen sind damit wir
wirklich objektive wahrheit haben können
zum beispiel wenn es eine idee oder form
der gerechtigkeit gibt nur diese form
die idee ist irgendwie über uns oder
mindestens nicht subjektive von uns
gestaltet ist sondern eine 1 1 der welt
und ist und das heißt dass der begriff
der gerechtigkeit irgendwie ein
objektives basis hat oder eine objektive
wahrheit oder essence
wie auch immer hat und deswegen gibt es
kann man es schon sagen es gibt falsche
und richtige antwort zu der frage was
ist die gerechtigkeit oder in jedem
einzelnen fall was werdet ihr es hier in
diesem fall die antwort ist immer das
was an der idee der gerechtigkeit
teilhaben würde aber wir kommen später
dazu dass also diskutieren diese ideen
näher kommt übrigens gar nicht im
männern vor sodass ist susan der
hintergrund und die problemstellung die
plattform hier betrachtet und das ich
glaube dass ein laser von damals hätte
das alles sofort im kopf gehabt nachdem
er den ersten satz des dialoges liest
also es geht sofort das ist diese
typische frage die man mit den
zuschüssen verbindet können wir sie die
türen lernen oder nicht und wenn und
wenn schon heißt es dass sie uns
beibringen können einfach politisch
mächtig zu sein oder weiß ist dass sie
nur überzeugung liefern oder gibt es
objektive trugen die sie vermitteln
müssen oder wie oder also das hätte man
wahrscheinlich sofort erkannt und das
würde man auf jeden fall erkennen wenn
man weiterliest dort den dialog
ok dann wie wie können wir dann diese
frage beantworten ob die tugend ist oder
ob die tugend lehrer ist oder nicht
magath es typischerweise das wissen sie
wahrscheinlich alle socket kalt ist es
für ihn ist die einstellung
dass er selber kein wissen besitzt also
er weiß nie was die richtige antwort
dass jemand die verlesung langweile
gewundert aber es war wirklich in
minderzahl ist es gut
jetzt sind wir alle einig ok also das
was er ist sofort sagt auf diese also
wie er diese frage beantwortet ist
natürlich kann ich nicht sagen ob die
tunnel ehrbar ist oder nicht weil ich
nicht weiß was die tugend ist und man
sollte die seite zwei methoden ein
gespräch zu führen entweder stellt er
eine frage weil er selbst keine ahnung
hat oder eine frage wird ihm bestellt
und dann sagt er dass er keine frage hat
und statt die frage zurück das ist immer
wie er dann gespräche führt und so macht
ja auch hier
er sagt zu mir ich weiß nicht ob die
tour war ist wie könnte ich das wissen
weil es mir so geht wie viele andere in
athen geht
wir sind nicht so schlau und wir haben
keine weisheit und wir wissen nicht
einmal was die tugend ist und wenn ich
nicht weiß was sie tun ist natürlich
kann ich nicht wissen ob die tuba ist
oder nicht
übrigens das ist interessant und kurz
überlegen das typisch für männer das
anhand dieses beispiels ein eine
breitere philosophische käse so anpassen
entwickelt wird was er sagt ist wenn wir
vielleicht das wesen eines dinges
erkennen können
dann können wir daraus weitere
eigenschaften dann erschließen
zum beispiel wenn man wissen würde dass
menschen tiere sind würde man dann die
frage beantworten ob tiere menschen sind
es wahrnehmen besitzen wenn alle tiere
sinneswahrnehmungen besitzen dann
schauen
also also ich würde sagen es ist in dem
begriff des menschen dass menschen tiere
sind das vielleicht sensationelle tiere
und in dem begriff des tieres ist
sinneswahrnehmung zu besitzen
deswegen wenn wir wissen was das wesen
des menschen ist können wir weitere
eigenschaften entdecken oder erklären
das ist das also was ich gerade gesagt
habe das ist genau die theorie die ihr
wissen möglich theorie die wir bei des
ortes finden und ein späterer
platonischer würde ich sagen ja ja
natürlich findet man das bei eishockeys
habe ich schon im klaren war hier in
männern haben wir ein paradebeispiel
genau dieses gedankengang okay also
sollte dies hat keine ahnung ob die
tugend der bar ist oder nicht und
deswegen das mähen und seine eigene
frage beantworten
allerdings müssen wir als leer als leser
dass es eine sehr typische sokratische
these gibt also eine these die
mannheimer mit sorgt dies in verbindung
bringen würde
die anscheinend eine antwort auf diese
frage liefern könnte nämlich wenn die
tugend nicht überzeugen ist oder
sonstwas oder ein oder vielleicht eine
angewohnheit die an das wort gesagt
vielleicht sein würde oder einfach ein
geschenk gottes sondern wenn die tilgung
wenn die tugend wissen werde werde sie
wahrscheinlich leer war
weil das sie es selber tue ich gerade ja
ich lerne wissen über platten
hoffentlich und nicht nur nicht nur
überzeugen
also wenn wenn die tugend wissen ist und
angenommen wissen es immer leer ba
hätten wir die antwort auf diese frage
und es ist vielleicht ein bisschen
rätselhaft warum sokratis mit einfach
sagt ja ich die frage gibt keine schon
beantworten weil nach mehr typisch ist
ich habe dieses typische sokratische
these ich bin so katies also nicht
überraschenderweise vertrete ich diese
sokratische these nämlich die tugend ist
wissen und wir wissen das wissen er ist
also ja dass die antwort warum sagt er
das nicht hier
vielleicht weil er nur die vermutung hat
das tugend wissen sein könnte kann es
aber nicht beweisen oder zeigen also
erst selbst hat keine kein wissen ob die
tugend wissen ist oder nicht sondern nur
überzeugungen oder meinungen und was er
haben will es wissen
also ironischer weise kann er nichts
sagen dass die tugend wissen ist gerade
weil er wissen weil wissen ihm fehlt und
was ja von männern haben will ist eine
definition der tugend womit wir wirklich
begründen können dass die tugend der ba
ist wenn man sagen würde wissen
instituten das wissen dann würde sagte
die sagen okay interessante definition
jetzt können wir das betrachten ob das
stimmt oder nicht
aber das ist nichts am hut - antwort
allerdings überlegen wieso es plausibel
wäre zu sagen dass die tugend wissen ist
und wie soll es flexibel ist darüber
zweifel zu haben
nehmen wir eine typische themen wie zum
beispiel tapferkeit oder frömmigkeit
es ist naheliegend zu sagen dass diese
tugend ist wenn sie nicht wissen sind
diese mit wissen sehr stark verbunden
weil zb wie wie kann ich fromm sein
ich muss nur wissen was zu tun ist wenn
ich so wie wenn ich mich so verhalten
will dass die götter mit mir zufrieden
sind
das ist fromm sein also wenn ich das
weiß dass zum beispiel was muss sich
opfern im tempel
dann kann ich für uns sein also ich
brauche nur dieses wissen oder was muss
ich das was man sich tun um tapfer zu
sein
ich muss nur wissen wie ich mich im
krieg verhalten soll
ja das sollten sie es auch sagt im krieg
ist es nicht die idee es nicht einfach
darzustellen und zu kämpfen
egal was passiert sondern zu wissen wann
man stehen und kämpfen sollen war nichts
und vielleicht jemand helfen soll
also welche methoden mit man einsetzen
soll
und so weiter und so sowohl sobald man
das wissen hat hat man die tugend ich
weiß was zu tun ist und dann mache ich
das leider die wir alle aus eigener
erfahrung wissen oder vielleicht sie
nicht aber ich schon reicht es auch
nichts zu wissen was man was zu tun ist
man musste es auch man muss es auch
einsetzen zum beispiel beispiel aus
meinem leben die ich gehe sehr gern zum
zahnarzt und und ich hatte einen satz
der in ruhestand gegangen ist
aber ich habe das im oktober ein brief
erfahren dass ich einen neuen zahnarzt
war musste ich war eigentlich ungefähr
fällig für die nächste für den nächsten
termin also hätte ich sollte vielleicht
im dezember zum sein als noch mal gehen
nächste woche gehe ich endlich zum
zahnarzt
weil ich so irgendwie geläutet haben
einen neuen zahnarzt zu finden
anderes zu tun jetzt bin ich krank
das hätte ist es hätten sogar heute
seien aber gestern deutlich superhelden
krank wie kann das eine woche
verschieben
und wenn sie mich gefragt hätten im
januar
es ist gut dass sie jetzt länger warten
den zusatz zu gehen hätte ich gesagt
nein das eine ganz schlechte idee weil
man immer zum song als gehen und kinder
nehmen wir einmal gründlich die zähne
putzen und genügend schlafen und gemüse
essen
also ich hätte hätte natürlich sofort
gesagt natürlich muss man sich zum song
als sie genug doch wie blöd wieso machst
du das dann nicht ja ich werde machen
irgendwann und es gibt ähnliche
beispiele also wie wir essen oder
rauchen oder nicht wie viel wir
fernsehen wie viel wir viel viel lesen
und andere sachen tun wir wissen dass
wir eigentlich nur spaß am essen viel
schlafen zähneputzen den fluss wir lesen
sollten und sonst gar nichts
aber trotzdem machen der andere sachen
wir machen facebook auf wenn wir wissen
dass das zeitverschwendung ist
apropos teldafax und dieses phänomen
heißt auf altgriechisch acacia
buchstäblich heißt es fehlende kontrolle
also wenn man die sich selbst nicht
meistert das engagiert und aggressiv und
vieles offen jetzt immer noch verwenden
dieses wort als ob das ein wurde auf
englisch oder deutsch wäre klasse wenn
das hat offensichtlich mit der
sokratischen these zu tun aber nach sagt
der sokratischen these würde jeder der
weiß was zu tun ist das sofort tun weil
die tugend ist nur wissen und ein
problem für diese theorie ist dass die
tugend doch nicht nur wissen halt
vielleicht hat es irgendwas mit wissen
zu tun kann aber nicht nur aus wissen
bestehen weil sonst würde man nie den
fall haben wo man weiß was tugendhaft zu
tun ist zu sein aber das nicht tut alles
tun wir alle jeden tag
okay wir werden später sehen dass er in
der polit er eine erklärung dafür
entwickelt habe die der socke thüs und
den vielen dialogen scheint aggressive
einfach als ein schein phänomen
abzulegen wie wir bald sehen werden
ok jetzt zurück zum dialog
was ist bisher geschehen sehr wenig ich
habe jetzt ungefähr eine seite
beschrieben ist
neben uns fragt ob die tuba ist sollte
sagt ich weiß es nicht
musst du mir sagen zuerst was die tun
ist und dann können wir darüber sprechen
ob sie lieber ist oder nicht
und dann sagt man na ja die frage ist
leicht zu beantworten
dieses klassische anfängerfehler leicht
zu beantworten
wenn du mich fragst was ist die tugend
eines mannes sage ich in dem hinter
statt zu regieren und macht ausüben wenn
du mich fragst was ist die tugend einer
frau zu hause zu bleiben und die familie
für die familie sorgen
sein beispiel mit mainz was die tun
eines pferdes oder eines hundes leicht
zu beantworten und dann sagt sorgt dies
ironisch er ist oft ironische lustig er
sollte welch ein glück ich wollte ihn
nur eine tugend haben und ich krieg alle
diese ich viele tugenden habe ich wollte
doch eine einheitliche erklärung was die
türken lässt das beschreibt ja dass die
sogenannte ja bienenschwarm passage er
sagt wenn ich dich fragen würde was
bienen cent kunst und du mir sagen würde
es okay dass die es gibt diese art bühne
und dass diese art bühne ist gesund und
ich bin kein bienenexperte es gibt fünf
verschiedene arten von bienen und die
haben alle ihre für die verschiedene
eigenschaften ich durfte das sagen jaja
schon gut aber ich will wissen was sie
alle gemeinsam haben genau das ist hier
angenommen was er übrigens nicht zugibt
dass männern die einzelne tugend des
männern der männern frauen werden usw
definiert hat angenommen dass er diese
tugenden richtig ergriffen hat trotzdem
kann man fragen ok aber was haben sie
alle gemeinsam damit sie alle tugenden
sind
was ist die tugend an sich
interessanterweise scheint es dass man
als lehrer ausdrücklich behauptet hat
dass man die tugenden im allgemeinen
nicht definieren kann sondern nur
einzeln für verschiedene zum beispiel
arten von menschen zb hinter sagt auch
es gibt eine tugend für die sklaven die
für den freien mann nicht passend ist
und wenn man sich wenn man davon ausgeht
dass alle diese verschiedene arten von
menschen und auch nicht menschen wie
tiere wenn sie alles hallen das
gemeinsam haben müsste dann findet man
gar nichts es gibt keine gemeinsame
nummer die man alle tugenden reduzieren
kann es gibt nur die einzelne tugend das
sagt mir dass dort ließ man scheint habe
nichts in der vorlesung nicht aufgepasst
zu haben und sagt okay in dem fall kann
ich dir schon sagen was die was sie tun
ist die truppe im allgemeinen ist die
fähigkeit zu regieren
und hier sehen wir noch mal wie eng
diese touristische einstellung mit
politischer macht verbunden ist also wie
für ihn ist die tugend letzten endes
gemacht zu haben und macht ausüben
vielleicht wäre es hier nicht fehl am
platz zu sagen was die kriegt das
richtige wort für tugend ist
adt
das könnte man auch als exzellenz oder
vortrefflichkeit übersetzen und deswegen
ist es nicht so komisch das heißt zum
beispiel von einer tugend dass der
experten spricht man kann ein
exzellentes wert haben nämlich ein
gesundes großes mächtiges wert und hier
scheint ja eher an menschlichen leben zu
denken und behauptet dass mindestens
unter menschen die tugend also exzellenz
zusammen ist macht zu haben oder als zu
reagieren
[Applaus]
exzellenz in daten weise die mit der
exzellenzinitiative verwenden ist macht
haben dann erwidert sagte thiess werde
es aber tugend wenn man ungerecht
regieren würde
oder muss man gerecht regieren um die
tugend zu besitzen oder zu zeigen und
dann sagt man und natürlich dass man
tugendhaft sein also gerecht regieren
muss um türen letzte sein
also müssen die definition dann
modifizieren und was hinzufügen tugend
ist nicht regieren zu können also nicht
nicht die nicht zumindest sich die
fähigkeit zu regieren sondern die
fähigkeit gerecht zu reagieren und das
denn gut dass auf die tatsache dass
gerechtigkeit eine tugend ist also ist
der akku leer
man sagt okay ich versuche noch mal die
tugend ist ich habe übrigens all diese
definition nach dem herrn mit den
einwänden aber sie können das mit folgen
nächste nächstes versucht die tugend ist
gute sache wollen und sie erwerben zu
können okay
und dann sagt sotheby's ja das eine
komische definition wer hätte gedacht
dass alle menschen gute sachen wollen
oder oder gibt es menschen die schlechte
sachen wollen und er sagt einem remis
kann sicher sein sagt sorge betrachten
wir das so ist das gute nicht
vorteilhaft auffällig oft wie gesagt mir
natürlich will jemand das haben was
nicht vorteilhaft ist natürlich nicht
dann will man nicht das geschlecht ist
und immer das gute so stimmt also dieser
teil der definition gute sachen zu
wollen ist überflüssig ist sozusagen
immer erfüllt das und das geht ziemlich
schnell
und das kann man leicht übersehen dass
das das ist genau das moment in diesem
dialog wo die typische sokratische these
vorkommt wenn man wissen würde was gut
ist würde man immer das richtige machen
weil alle menschen immer das gute wollen
es gibt keine für ihn gibt es keine
aggressiv weil motivation einfach
eingebaut ist
in dem gut wenn das gute erkennen als
gut
muss ich das erstrebenswert finden dass
man könnte sogar sagen mindestens ein
teil davon der der idee was als gutes
omen ist dieses ding erstellten swertz
zu empfinden und er würde wahrscheinlich
sagen über mein mann mein problem ein
psychisches problem mit dem seines
führerscheines an
du behauptest dass du das gut finde ist
aber im märz findest du das offiziell
nicht gut sonst würdest du allen einen
termin mit dem zahnarzt zu machen aber
vielleicht hat er sogar recht okay
zum glück bleibt was von dieser
definition übrig die definition war gute
sachen zu wollen und sie erwerben zu
können
selbst wenn wir alle gute sachen wollen
also da dieser teil ist überflüssig
bleibt die ein halbsatz sie erwerben zu
können also gute sachen erwerben sie
könnten vielleicht ist das die tugend
die truppen werde einfach gute sachen
erwerben zu können also die fähigkeit
gute sachen für mich zu erwerben das
klingt gut an bis sorgt hier ist dann
fragt macht es keinen unterschied wie
ich die gute sachen erwerbe muss ich sie
zum beispiel nicht gerecht erwerben zum
beispiel sein geld gut ist wenn ich geld
klauen würde oder wenn macht's gut ist
und wenn ich um die regierung stürzen
würde
oder in einer in einer wahl lügen würde
und um die wahl zu gewinnen und wenn ich
so an die macht kommen würde wäre das
trug die tugend natürlich nicht ich muss
das gerät machen
[Musik]
dann müssen wir wieder einbauen dass die
tugend ist gute sache näher werden zu
können aber immer gerecht aber
gerechtigkeit ist seine tugend sie
wieder zirkuliert also wieder
gescheitert und hier verzweifelt männern
und sagt dass er nichts besseres ein
paar zu bieten hat und dann wird es
wirklich spannend was danach kommt bevor
wir sie diesen zweiten teil kommen dafür
die und die letzten zehn minuten dazu
widmen wollte ich aber nur nur bemerken
dass dieses die diese ganze erste hälfte
oder vielleicht drittel des dialogs
nicht immer ein natürlich ist es
einerseits eine diskussion diskussion
der tugend aber es ist auch und
vielleicht sogar wichtiger
das ist eine ein beweis oder darstellung
was eine gute philosophie definition
haben muss ein eigenschaften die ich
habe übrigens wieder übersprungen
es gibt einfach eine passage wo sokratis
ein beispiel liefert was er haben will
und er definiert figur grundfarbe man
sagt also wenn du mir ein so eine
definition für die turm geben würdest
wären zufrieden
und implizit in dieser ganzen passage
haben wir sozusagen eine darstellung von
den eigenschaften die jeder gute
definition haben muss sie mussten nicht
sehr cool er sein
sie muss also zum beispiel man man kann
nicht sagen
die tugend ist irgendwas gerecht zu
machen oder tugendhaft zu machen weil
das sehr gut ein zirkel ist
sie muss einheitlich sein
zum beispiel man kann nicht einfach eine
liste geben das ist dass dieses problem
mit dem bienenschwarm und sie muss keine
gegenbeispiele haben zum beispiel fragt
wenn er sagt dass die tugend die
konstrukteure gern oder die fähigkeit zu
regieren bemerkt ausdrucke tier ist dass
das sind sklaven mit passend ist
natürlich also wenn eine definition
einheitlich ist keine gegenbeispiele hat
wohl nicht sehr cooler ist dann könnte
man mindestens hoffen dass das die
richtige definition ist und was wirklich
interessant ist ist dass er hier
wirklich formale bedingungen dann
dargestellt hat also man nach nachdem
man das gelesen hat weiß man so sagen
wie man methodisch in der philosophie
vorzugehen ist nämlich definitionen
suchen die diese bedingungen erfüllen
und diese abstrakte ist sozusagen
zweiter ordnung überlegung wie eine
definition und deswegen wissen
ausschauen könnte
das würde würde sogar sagen hier in
diese diesem dialog erfasst erfunden das
eigentlich der erste text in der
geschichte der philosophie der so etwas
tut
es ist beeindruckend wenn das nicht
schon genug wäre haben wir dann die
berühmteste passat passage wo man wie
gesagt verzweifelt ist und sagt sollten
du bist wie einen stachelrochen wenn du
mich wenn ich in kontakt mit ihr komme
werde ich stumm oder gelähmt
bei vorher dachte ich dass ich will dass
ich wüsste was die tugend ist habe jetzt
habe ich keine ahnung
und dann sagt männern deshalb sagt sagte
thies du willst diese diese vergleiche
einführung nur war dass du so hübsch
passt eine hübsche leute immer
vergleiche machen wollen damit sie mit
was schönes verglichen werden
und du weißt dass ich auf hübsche männer
stehe
erst sagt ja dass uns weiter sagt ja
wenn ich wie ein schachen bin dann
einfach noch einen der sich selbst einen
paralysieren kann weil ich bin auch hier
dann verzweifelt und weiß weiß auch mit
viva die jugend definieren sollten
und hier könnte man vorstand wenn es ein
typ wirklich ein typischer für dialog
werde würde es hier aufhören
die sorge ist würde vielleicht sagen
aber natürlich ist es so wichtig dass
wir herausfinden was die souvenirs
person immer weiter suchen und nicht
aufgeben
ok dann würde ich sagen okay die end
aber hier gehen wir noch klar in diese
methodische richtung auf die abstrakte
ebene wo wir überlegen wie wir
methodisch vorgehen können also wie
wissen möglich ist und was ich nicht
verstehe ist wenn wir nicht wissen was
die tugend ist wie können wir sie finden
weil wir wissen eigentlich nicht was
besuchen und wie werden wir sie erkennen
nachdem wir sie gefunden haben und das
ist natürlich eine gute frage
also wenn ich irgendwas definieren will
aber ich weiß nicht was dieses ding erst
wie erstens wie kann ich vorgehen und
zweitens wenn ich die antwort finde wie
werde ich wissen was das die antwort ist
er habe keine ahnung was das ding ist
und dann sagt sie das ist eine ein
lustiges paradox was zuvor bringst und
ich glaube was du meinst ist sowas und
dann beschreibt er das etwas anders als
ein und gesagt hat und er sagt das was
eigentlich her auf dem handel habe es
gibt zwei möglichkeiten
für jedes objekt also ein ex entweder
habe ich wissen über dieses objekt oder
nichts
also ich weiß ex oder nicht ich weiß wir
müssen vielleicht was ist oder nicht
wenn ich schon weiß was das ist musste
ich es nichts untersuchen weil ich schon
wissen habe ist ein relativ klar sein
aber wenn nicht kann ich nicht suchen
weil ich nicht weiß was ich suche und an
dass das heißt maine paradox oder
untersuche das untersuchung ist paradox
auf englisch heißt es manchmal bei
apriori und scheint ein riesen problem
zu sein für die ganze technologie also
mit diesem problem könnte man eine
vorlesung in psychologie anfangen
genauso gut wie eine vorlesungsreihe
über antike fluss das problem ist dass
wir anscheinend nie aus eine den der
startposition des unwissens kommen
können weil wir nicht wissen wer ohne
uni ohne dessen wissen nichts die
mitteln haben weiterzukommen
wie können wir dieses problem lösen oft
jedes gesagt dass das paradox leicht zu
lösen ist weil man nicht nur wissen
haben kann
komplettes wissen sondern auch teilweise
was wissen was wissen kann weil wir das
nochmal an er sagt entweder weiß ich das
ding oder nicht wenn ich das ding weiß
bin ich schon da so sagen es gibt nichts
zu tun
aber das müssen nicht unbedingt der fall
sein ich konnte ihn nur irgendwas nur
teilweise wissen zum beispiel ich könnte
nicht wissen was einen stachelrochen ist
wissen aber schon dass das und ob ich
wirklich weiß was einen stachelrochen
das bin ich nicht so sicher aber ich
weiß dass das
lebt ok also ich stehe ja nichts mit
null sondern haben teilweise wissen über
der stachel löcken und jetzt muss ich
nur irgendwie alle dinge im see dann
untersuchen
okay aber ich denke dass diese lösung
hört man sehr oft und ließ man in der
sekundärliteratur ich finde aber dass
diese lösung
falsch ist weil sie das paradox nicht
ernst nimmt
bei der punkt war wenn ich keinen wissen
besitze wie kann ich wissen erlangen wie
kann ich wissen erwerben
das gilt genauso gut für teil wissen als
für ganz wissen also man kann fragen
okay wie habe ich herausgefunden dass
ein stachelrochen im seele dann habe ich
wissen anscheinend habe ich das einmal
entweder gewusst und ich habe das
irgendwie herausgefunden aber wie habe
ich das herausgefunden wenn ich am
anfang in einer situation des unwissens
war also man kann genauso gut fragen wie
man von unwissen zuteil wissen kommt als
wie man von unwissen zu komplettes
wissen kommt
also diese lösung ist nicht gut glaube
ich zocke dies hat eine andere lösung
nämlich die die ich gerade fast erwähnt
habe seine theorie das ist die so
genannte erinnerungs theorie das
griechische team astana - das heißt
buchstäblich noch mal daran erinnert zu
sein oder nochmals zu merken und die
idee ist dass die seele schon immer
existiert hat auch vor vor unseren
geburt und jetzt in diesem leben und
heute jetzt in diesem leben wenn wir
anscheinend neue sachen lernen also
neues wissen erwerben was tatsächlich
passiert ist dass wir davon erinnert
werden von dem was wir schon vor dem
geburt gewusst haben
die serie hat wissen über alle dinge hat
immer schon gehabt und muss irgendwie
nur daran erinnert werden um dieses
wissen aktiv zu machen
um das zu beweisen dann nimmt sorgt sie
ein anwesen des sklaven kennt und zeigt
männern dass er diese sklaven kennt so
mathematisches wissen bringen kann nur
dadurch dass er fragen stellt
das scheint eine platonische überlegung
zu sein
wieso es sinnvoll war das sorglose wie
in dieser art und weise gemacht hat
nämlich immer wieder fragen zu stellen
die idee war anscheinend wenn er immer
wieder und die richtigen fragen stellt
kommen leute auf ihr internes wissen was
ihnen im moment nicht zugänglich ist
sie werden daran erinnert was sie schon
wissen und in einem anderen dialog
namens feiern
wird dieses phänomen als argument für
die unsterblichkeit der seele erfolg
gebracht weil die idee ist wenn es
wirklich stimmt dass wir alles nur immer
nur märkten oder davon erinnert werden
und ist neues lernen dann müssen wir
schon vor der geburt existiert haben als
das heißt dass die zelle schon
unabhängig von der körper gelebt hat das
ist natürlich eine sehr starke these und
ist vielleicht für uns lag zu stark für
als lösung für dieses anscheinend nicht
so schwieriges problem
es seien also für alle kirsch 11 ist
dass wir wir hatten eine relativ
einfache es ein relativ einfaches es ein
mögliches problem
man findet plötzlich postulieren wir
dass die seele immer körperlos existiert
hat damit dass die seele alles wissen
kann und ob das wirklich mit unserer
erfahrung das dahin im leben web profil
sachen lernen als nicht so klar ob wir
technologisch sozusagen das ist so
empfinden dass jedes mal dass wir lernen
was lernen dass wir wirklich das gefühl
haben dass wir an irgendwas erinnert
werden
und eine mögliche auslegung die diese
theorie einerseits ernst nimmt aber
andererseits vielleicht klaus supermacht
würde zum beispiel von genf ein einen
klartraum eine plattform vorstellen
vorgeschlagen
sie hat gemeint dass platz als problem
hier ist eigentlich folgendes er gibt zu
dass leute in der regel immer war der
meinung haben was sie nicht haben ist
wissen und das sehen wir sogar bei
männern zum beispiel kann sagen was ist
die tugend eines mannes einer frau eines
pferds und das kann er richtig sagen was
er nicht kann machen kann ist
allgemeinwissen zu haben über die typen
zu haben was es ist was sie erst was sie
tun ist wesentlich ist also die frage
ist wie kommen wir von wahrer meinungen
zu wissen
antwort durch befrager die mit dem
sklaven kennt also ich habe all diese
waren meinungen haben leider vielleicht
auch falsche meinungen die darunter
gemäß sind und vorhanden sind sind meine
wahre meinungen sehr instabil
ich kann hd engine können mich
überzeugen dass meine meinung falsch
sind oder ich kann zb manchmal recht
haben manchmal nichts deswegen
vergleichsplattform später im dialog war
der meinung mit einem magischen skulptur
die sehr schön ist aber die so echt ist
dass sie weglaufen kann also war die
meinung ist super weil sie war erst aber
sie ist nicht zuverlässig dass der punkt
und damit wir die meinungen die wir
haben nicht nur war kriegen sondern auch
festgelegt brauchen wir irgendwas
irgendeine bindung dass das nennt er
später eine überlegung des gründers
nicht so klar was das heißen
sollte aber wir brauchen irgendeine
überlegung mit wem wir die meinung nimmt
und da aus der meinung wissen schaffen
also hier haben wir eine weitere sehr
grundlegende frage der technologie
nämlich was ist die beziehung zwischen
meinung und wissen also in ein geschäft
ist möglich man spricht man von berief
einnahmen also meinung oder überzeugung
kann war seien aber nur war der meinung
oder überzeugungen zu haben ist noch
nicht genug
das ist was die sophisten im bestenfalls
anbieten konnten was wir aus philosophen
wollen ist nicht nur meine wahr oder
falsch sondern wissen sicherheit und
eine frage die uns durch diese kommende
vorlesungen folgenden ist eine frage die
platte und durch viele dialoge unter
anderem die polit er bespricht und die
in wirklich sehr beschäftigt hat nämlich
genau diese frage also was ist wissen
wie verhält sich wissen zu meinen und
wie können wir nicht nur meinung haben
sondern auch müssen
ok also diese themen werden werden den
kommenden wochen sehen aber jetzt danke
dass sie gekommen sind und bis nächste
woche